certainly the man of the hour two and a
half out of three a dream start for you
hans okay what's your opinion
it's not bad no he just he played quite
poorly so
uh i didn't do anything special he just
went well okay i think i played quite
well
but uh i was actually very fortunate
that this opening came on the board and
i looked at this today
and you you guessed this opening today i
don't guess it but but some miracle i
had checked this today and it's like
it's
such such a ridiculous miracle
that that i don't even remember why i
checked it i just went
when i saw
i just remembered
h6 and everything after this and i have
no idea why i would check such a
ridiculous thing
but i checked it and i even knew that
the bishop e6 is uh
just very good like it's so ridiculous
that i checked it but uh so you you
actually this morning had this position
yeah even farther
where did it stop well okay you should
play bishop six
uh here at this position yeah well on a
different sub-variation it goes farther
so no let's see not rook d-1 this is a
mistake so i knew this is a mistake so
he could play so bishop of six queen of
six knight d2
queen b5 a6 queen b6 bishop g4
it was like a rook e1 i guess
and uh here there's a few moves
but i checked this today by a miracle
yeah you had this exact position even
further but uh i have to ask you come on
what what prompted you out of all the
variations to choose this one i don't
think that magnus has ever played this
before no he has he played against
wesley so in the longest classic 2018.
all right but it wasn't the specific
variation he played um
he played uh
it was with um
he did not play with the a3
and uh okay there were so here okay
let's say you can play knight of three
right that's maybe dc4
yeah castles knight c6
queen a495
well yeah
queen c2 and then bishop e7 is critical
to play e4 knight cb4
queen knight c before queen e2 knight
knight c3 cd3 and knight d3 black
slightly better
but anyways he played that no no he has
it i was expecting he has a tendency for
for these types of weird things
and um
considering how my repertoire and the
clash i expected something weird
and uh also this is a through there's a
game um
uh
chigave surrounded
uh sharjah
what's not with a3 let's say let's say
it goes like
basically
they reached um
he played this eighth grade idea it's
like across the pawn and it was
extremely dangerous so i remembered this
game because i was there and i was
watching it i never even checked it so i
was like
uh i was doing with the idea and um
even i played this g3 nimzo myself like
even five years ago so it's not like
maybe he should have checked my white
database to see how familiar i would be
but um
yeah a3 is just with takes in c5 it's
very concrete
and then uh
i think i vaguely remember
after h6 i think even even a queen h4
might be a move here
uh
right now yeah what does it say what
does engine say okay it's not no not
here not human okay maybe i remember
some queen h4 but
but yeah okay uh after bishop e6 is just
quite difficult but still i think i
played really well i was very happy you
know i had some great let's okay let's
go i want to enjoy it too
it's your show man it's really it's
really nuanced you know like let's let's
where do we go uh just from bishop
bishop b6
that's it okay so so
rick d8 okay already here
okay you can i'll tell you what yeah so
take take this end game take thank yes
okay
of course yeah knight d8 95 and i was
very happy because ricky wouldn't now
ricky it's very counter-intuitive
right and there's okay there's a
critical line you know he was thinking
he's going to trick me but let's say
right d1 king d1 this is very critical
uh okay bishop d5 right yep now okay
let's say 1991 take take knight c4 a49
right
but okay so instead of this he can't
okay when the pawn so so uh he has a
trick um let's go beginning of variation
okay where after bishop d5 you can play
king c2
and the point is after king c2 is let's
say knight c4
he wants to play knight d2 but there's
just knight a3 so first he plays a4
let's go a little bit a4 then knight b6
then a5 then knight c4 then 92.
ah so this is the little you know trick
so he he
this wasn't gonna work but the
interesting yeah so we analyzed a
different one uh okay i'll show you that
one because this one uh instead of a4 he
has knight e3 in this position yeah but
um
i think for him to play this oh take
some c4
yeah that's that's uh it's too much
that's way too much
all right so you won rook c8 which is
definitely the best move in the position
yes and then 92 bishop b6 i just kept
pressure and then he went c4 yeah and
after this i was uh bishop c4 you know
take take yeah okay we can i'll tell you
when to stop yeah there was some
critical moment
um
yeah
i was very happy with this f5 move on
move 26 i was very happy with this i
thought this was very critical
and then ricky eight e4 yeah so i could
tell that
maybe okay it says 0.6 but practically
it felt so difficult and i had a slight
time edge yeah g4 this is the the big
mistake that is a big mistake and then i
and then i capitalized yeah perfectly
i wouldn't go that perfectly really
there was a can can i yeah of course uh
we'll go g4 i'll tell you that says he
did evaluate this at zero zero so really
yes
mistake
so rook c5
bishop a2 it didn't like your knight c4
should i play instead i
i think it wanted to take on g4 because
it thinks that the end game after bishop
takes c4 is a draw
actually doesn't think it knows but it's
difficult of course
to say that bishop c4 is a draw is like
the most computer thing ever
like i guarantee you turn the engine off
you ask a hundred grand masters yeah
bishop c4 working for ef5 rook a4 what
is the evaluation
like maybe 99 will say it's lost like
i don't even want you to explain it to
me because then it will just i'll lose
my humanity
let's keep your humanity so let's keep
going
like if you want to explain to me that
bishop is a draw like
you know then then you should just i'm
not the chess player anymore right
because like come on it's like come on
like bishop c okay let's just show it
for a second yeah okay like i thought
you wanted to give your shift rook c4
ef5 rook a4 okay like like this is the
the classic thing you get b5 you hold it
then you go king f6 like this is not the
draw i don't care what the computer says
it's not a drone all right i understand
okay so okay we can continue and then
after this so if you're saying that um
so so basically the basis of everything
is some you know uh of of um knight's
four being your stake is this is then
it's the best move in my opinion all
right fair enough better than the engine
rook e7 in this position f takes g5 yes
yes and you had this nice trick of rook
d7 and e3 he could go rook d8 and then i
play e3 as well yes instead in this
position
that was the that was the killer um yeah
you still it's the game going on no but
it's it's very difficult like it's not
uh it's not like you can just uh
rookie two but it was always very close
but uh yeah yeah it was very close
rookie yeah i just wanted to
yeah i felt like practically was going
to be winning here so i just made a
repetition because objectively if i have
more time then i should be able to find
it if the wind's there then i should
repeat to have more time right because i
had more time i could arguably not
repeat
to to um
to press on the clock but i thought it
was no reason yeah so king f6 i was very
happy with what i did here so bishop d5
yeah
would you would it surprise you to know
that this position is actually holdable
for white okay again you know you're
speaking we're speaking different
languages here
well let's take a look uh so bishop d5
was his choice what else were you
expecting in this position well so
there's red picked p7 yeah but so so
here there are many there are some
nuances yeah so first there is
there's uh two moves knight g5 and rig
d2 correct so rook d2 i thought was very
nice
and at this moment okay let's first
check the ng5 because i want to show why
i didn't like it okay knight g5 yeah
bishop d5 not h3 yeah bishop d5 actually
does lose for white
well then okay
then i'm not then i played volumes
no you're not saying he didn't play well
you know
okay okay
but
yeah so this bishop d5 that is three
king f1 rick f2 king i evaluated this is
very close but i thought it should be
winning this check and then rick issue
yes and then rookie yes yes so i was
like okay if this is the winning then
you know
what to do
correct
all right so but after bishop d5 you
definitely played perfectly in this
position yeah that's true yeah when did
you know for sure that you had it in the
back
actually in this position after rook d2
sorry i actually made a mistake g6 again
this rook end game was apparently
yeah i know zero zero
still
you know we're not communicating here
it's like a failed relationship you know
you're you're looking at it's not one
thing and i'm like i'm thinking about
the practical and you're just like you
know hard this is this is this is you
know that's why they put me in front of
the board
that's why you're there playing
you know we're just not
you know if you tell me that okay when
i'm making decisions and i see okay he
can go for this no but actually i wasn't
even gonna go for the reckon game let me
correct you wreck four i have knight g5
okay and then bishop gt and then king h5
and then you were going for this okay
this was the the idea right yeah so this
uh i don't know how you're holding this
because i go kn i go h5 then i have
threats not h3 i have b5 pushing like
this should be lost no
it should be should be again again uh
sitting here with with white especially
yeah it's just you're and already he's
demoralized right exactly because uh you
know tell us about the body language of
the world champion at certain stages
like for example here after reaching mu
40 he actually didn't get up from the
board like he normally does he kept
himself on the board well you know he
has little ticks you know and i've
noticed that okay that's maybe
i should not use that word um he has
mannerisms
don't want to get cancelled here
mannerisms please thank god i said that
i corrected myself mannerisms so you
know when i've played him i noticed
sometimes when he wants to assert
dominance he cracks a little smile
and he wasn't cracking many smiles maybe
one or two and that made me feel very
good because i just again of course i
grew up watching him i grew up i've
watched all of his interviews and
and you know
and he said once an interview that
he spent more than 10 minutes on a move
that's a very bad sign and he did that a
lot this game so that like that boosted
my confidence but i think okay even if
there's a draw yes
i think he's just so demoralized because
he's losing to such an idiot like me you
know it's just
it must be embarrassing for the world
champion to lose to me i feel bad for
him how do you see yourself you're two
and a half out of three in the
stingfield cup you consider yourself a
top player are you saying that if you
don't win this tournament
it's an issue
do i have a full point lead or a half
point lead i believe that it depends on
how wesley does right win
he well we haven't checked in a while
i'll just update real quick you know
what it's a mess i'm not going to call
it either way oh well that's ridiculous
yeah mg6 will move
yeah but it's been like that for a while
like bobby has been on the threat yeah
um so let's say that they draw and you
have a full point lead yeah
but still you know i'm of course uh i
believe that um
especially these three games have
encapsulated my strength and potential
as a player but you should know that i'm
still uh i'm still improving i'm still
learning and uh it's it's you don't
become world champion one day it's it's
a gradual uh process and i'm i'm
aware of of that it's it's you know this
chess thing is is a very long marathon
that's what's going to take a very long
time so if i don't win this tournament
okay who cares uh
the goal is not okay of course winning
tournaments but um the eventual goal is
to improve you know chess and become
world champion because in my opinion i
see it's sort of black and white for me
right
you know i see a lot of players who have
been top 10 for very long in their
career and
you know they're happy you know with
cashing in but for me it's
top ten or all this it doesn't really
mean much uh i think in chess uh
the striving to be the greatest is is
for me the motivation of course it's a
long way to go but
uh to to answer questions
shorter way
of course i would like to win the
tournament if i don't win the tournament
it happens but
again the goal is to play good chess and
i'm doing that so far bruce and kasir
janov mentioned in another broadcast
that some of these players
rating hasn't caught up to the juniors
and these players are not as strong as
they used to be in your opinion do you
think this top 10 is currently overrated
compared to the juniors i wouldn't well
you know
overrated is uh is you could also say
they're underrated right so it goes both
ways so i would currently say that
they're a group of let's say you know
maybe you can even say 10 of the
greatest
of very strong junior players including
myself maybe 10 is a bit much but i will
say that the the structure of um
the the tournament system is is in a way
that it
is difficult for um players to to reach
the elite of chess um
because you have a lot of these open
tournaments you know for me i took the
path right i was a year and a half ago
24 80. then life's great you can just
play any tournament you know i was
playing like gm around robins you know
and then okay i reached 2600 then i won
every single open there was then i
reached 26.50 and then it was already
difficult you know i had to try and get
the round robin invitation i had to try
and play the strong opens and even
though it was it was difficult now
obviously i'm very thankful to have the
opportunity to play stingfield cup u.s
championship this is great right so with
these tournament opportunities
that thankfully the same stressful
provides it's possible but not all top
junior players have these opportunities
so in my opinion if things were
restructured then the gap but it is very
clear that
the top 10 players in my opinion are
first of all they're the age is getting
quite high and they i don't feel the
same motivation in the fire
that the younger players have but it's
not to say that they're better than them
but we should look for ways to balance
opportunities
like even for me to get this invite is
is is perfect right yes if i didn't get
this invite i'd be going playing some
league uh for like you know some
ridiculous amount of money and paying me
on flight it's like
in terms of chess there's a
there's a gap
it's like you know the rich not the rich
get richer it's like all the top players
get their invites it's not like they're
bad or anything it's just that um
there are some players who i believe
have tremendous potential who just don't
get the opportunities and is that what
we saw at the olympia
yeah yeah the olympia had certainly uh
reflected that with like uh er guys
obviously tour of cuca showed great
results and that's probably the one
event where
they get to actually play the top
players right
so i guess in this regard uh this
tournament is showing you know i've been
winning every single term that i've
played in um now i get the chance to
play them and it's showing you know
i'm i'm not there's i'm i'm
i'm not bad at this game you know so so
uh this these opportunities are
important but i think the grand chester
is great in general right uh
st louis without saint louis chess would
be a complete joke in my opinion you
know so yeah well i'm gonna bring in
peter and yasser do you guys have any
questions here for hans we're not worthy
well done
i was specifically described as being
not worthy as well so i uh what
oh peter you're great
but yeah i mean it's a we could listen
to this for hours but we do have a game
going on but you think wesley wins this
this is the current position yeah and at
age six is
should be played quickly not quickly but
he has like 10 minutes no oh three
and it's the only move negative is the
only move he's sort of forced to find it
right yes he's already repeated twice so
you can't you sort of think like uh how
do i make a threat
and then the only move to make a threat
is
so uh you know he he'll find it he'll
find it and not nike yeah the
interesting point is not they say let me
clarify i don't want this be negatively
towards his players it's just sort of
tradition traditions right but uh
eventually i think the top players do
break through that's for sure like if
you're a strong player if you're really
really good eventually you're going to
be top 10 player right but um
it's chess is a difficult profession and
um
but i'm just thankful for the
opportunity so i can't really complain
right because i'm getting i've gotten
some very fortunate invitations this one
is like
if i didn't have this opportunity then
who knows how long it would take me to
to
show that i can beat top players right
because u.s championship maybe i play
top guys but when it can ever play
magnus carlsen right right
so this is a gift yeah not a gift but
it's it's true i'm very very thankful uh
for this opportunity
you've crossed 2700 for you it was a
given that it was going to happen very
soon oh i did yeah yes forgot about that
i guess that explained that answers my
question
that's okay but uh it's only the
beginning only the beginning
hans thank you for joining us candid as
always congratulations on your
performance so far definitely a big day
for you beating the world champion with
the black pieces
thank you for joining us thank you and
again uh hans our uh congratulations
good luck uh for the rest of the
tournament knight h6 on the board on the
board and wesley
looks like he's in the driver's seat
yeah as